some unaccompanied migrant children
stopped at the u.s
border are due to arrive today at a new
temporary detention center in dallas
the u.s is holding some 13 thousand
unaccompanied minors after a surge in
arrivals that began
in january when president biden took
office the rush to open
new holding facilities suggests the new
administration was not ready for this
migration and
critics say it should have been maria
villarreal is in mcallen texan
texas maria what's the president saying
about this
well good morning anthony the president
had his interview last night and his
message was clear to migrants
don't come and his reasoning was quote
we're in the process
of getting things set up but still
people are coming by the thousands many
of them children that will end up in
temporary facilities like this one but
as the government continues to get
things set up crossing the border is
just the beginning of a journey that
could be very long
and confusing
within minutes of filming a processing
center on the border agents ask us to
leave
you can't come out here
the media's access to federal run sites
has been restricted
making it harder to understand how the
process is working
but under a bridge that connects mexico
to the united states
we were able to see dozens of children
and adults
waiting for processing families are
given water snacks
and foil blankets while they wait to
officially enter the system
the unaccompanied minors are first held
in short-term centers like this
the only pictures provided are from the
government but lawyers tell us children
are going hungry
some showering once in seven days and in
conditions
so overcrowded that they had to take
turns sleeping on the floor
to get the children out faster makeshift
shelters like this one in dallas are
opening up
but it's not just migrants crossing
illegally that are testing the system
a brownsville parking garage a block
from the border has been converted into
a welcome center for migrants
who have crossed through a port of entry
and have been processed by the federal
government when migrant families arrive
they first come to this step with the
city of brownsville
and the folks here help them contact
their families
and start providing transportation
either by bus or by plane
around the country to reunite them with
their families and friends wherever
they're going
once the government is able to locate
relatives here in the u.s
some of the children who made their
journeys alone are reunited with their
families
leading to moments like this in los
angeles
a mother and her five-year-old hugging
for the first time
in more than four months apart
we've showed you what it's like to cross
the border we've now showed you what
it's like in some of these
facilities now the next step is to fight
for your asylum in these court cases or
in these court hearings
and that's a process that is overwhelmed
as well that system is overwhelmed some
families telling us they are waiting
years to have their cases
heard in court we have here real
continuing her powerful reporting there
along the border for us maria thank you
very much